it's played out in a lot of ways
I think it was probably the best
educational experience when I think
about like grad school and different you
know experiences of grad school being in
an environment that's predominantly
women really shaped my education
actually in ways that I didn't entirely
I think understand until I was teaching
undergrad students in a coed setting and
really saw some of the distinctions and
I almost a kind of college culture and
I'm sure some of its like small liberal
arts school big research university but
just things that I parts of college
culture I wasn't even aware of and I
think I guess you know some of my most
enduring relationships are from that
time in my life and in terms of the
research that I just did it's
interesting I was speaking with people
in girls detention facilities so they're
in while people have a lot of gender
identities and expressions there in a
you know setting that's designated as
being for girls or for women and so I
thought about that a lot i was doing the
research having gone to a school that
was also you know designated as being
for girls or women oh my god you know
it's so funny before when I was saying
there are things about academia that
sometimes felt like they contradicted
the work I was trying to do actually
expected IRB to be one of the hardest
parts and it went quite smoothly for me
I think it had largely to do with the
particular person who was reviewing my
work and who had some social work
backgrounds and was really interested in
what I was doing and thought it was
important and so she really you know
advocated and helped me Shepherd the the
application through the IRB process I
think it would have been way slower and
more challenging
if two things were the case one if I
were interviewing people who were under
18 and two if I were actually
interviewing people who were in
detention I also think if I were
detention I would have heard really
different things than what I did
I think that people would not have
trusted me as much I think that they
would have been much more apprehensive
about sharing some of the things that
happened to them in detention because
it's really a culture of retaliation
unfortunately I heard some horrific
stories about different kinds of
physical and sexual violence in
detention that one people made efforts
to report it it kind of made their
situation worse so
you
yeah I mean it's I think that we're not
really socialized to have those
conversations in a lot of contacts and
so it can be a little bit awkward but I
was so used to doing it from being a
practitioner and also from being an
activist and feeling like I'm oh wait
that's something I'm always you know
having conversations about and so I did
name it and sometimes people are like
what like I can't believe we're talking
about this but I felt like it was
important and I also felt like in some
ways it created more intimacy so I kind
of just did it
um so there was one into it was actually
my first interview and it was with a
trans identified woman who had had a
really bad experience in detention with
a lesbian actually who was her cellmate
and she was telling me the story and you
know was kind of apologizing in a way
for not what happened but she's like I'm
sorry like you know I I know a lot of
good game gay women and I was like it's
really okay you know this is the fact
that you're trusting me with this
information which I know it's hard for
you to say to me is an honor and I think
that was probably one of the more
actually intense interactions because it
was such a horrible story and horrible
experience and also because of the
unique aspects of our identity that were
coming into play in that conversation
did you say what was my training my
training was actually here in a lot of
my hit so I I did so there were not a
lot of offerings in my own Department
Social Work and around interpretive or
qualitative methods and definitely not
oral history specifically I took a lot
of courses in women gender and sexuality
studies and I found more of a home there
but my I think fourth year in the
program i attended the Summer Institute
and that's where I really got into oral
history and I think that was the first
time I learned about life history
interviewing I think actually from
Dorinda well he who also has done
research with LGBTQ youth and that was
like a breath of fresh air and also the
fact that it's not specific to any one
discipline I think makes it a little bit
of a liberating space
I think within my department I
definitely had to defend qualitative
methods more generally social work
although it seems really contradictory
is still really quantitatively driven
when it comes to research and I happen
to be in a program that is especially
quantitatively driven and I don't think
I realized just how much that was true
or what the like consequences or
pressures were once you're there and you
decide or you continue did you know do
what you said you wanted to do but I I
felt much more like within my department
I was having to kind of explain to some
people what I was doing my committee was
really supportive and I'm super grateful
for that but there were definitely
people who just didn't think of it as
credible research
I think cuz i had heard a lot of the
stories once already and i felt like
nothing could be more powerful than
these using those stories to advocate
advocate for change in policy practice I
think that numbers have their place and
they're worth and there are actually a
lot of numbers right now floating around
that are really useful about
over-representation of LGBTQ thand
racial disproportionality and child
welfare assistance but I think to get at
the trajectories of what's happening for
young people to really look at things
like the school to Prison Pipeline to
look at the nuances of identity you just
can't do that with like a survey you
know and I I think had I not if I were
going into a new community and not back
to a place where I'd already worked I
don't I wonder if I would have felt as I
can only call it stubborn as i was about
using this particular method i think in
a way i might have because it is really
also about who i am as a person but I
just really felt like the stats for this
community needed to be supplemented with
youth voice and and personal stories